hello ketchup crew welcome to the weekly
ketchup on YouTube where we bring you
the biggest news of the week in movies
and TV this week we'll talk about the
possibility of the Invisible Man
reviving the dark universe and what the
new Batmobile says about next year's the
Batman plus we're celebrating amazing
female directors in honor of
International Women's Day it's gonna be
fun here we go
you said that wherever I went he would
find me walk right up to me
and I wouldn't be able assisting him
well what do you know it the Invisible
Man was actually seen by a lot of people
according to the box office so now that
it's officially a hit with both critics
and fans let's take a look at what that
could mean for the future of the dark
universe right now on the ketchup the
Invisible Man which is certified fresh'
and currently has a strong audience core
of 88% is the latest reboot in the world
of the universal classic monsters which
date all the way back to the 1920s and
also includes characters like
Frankenstein Dracula and The Mummy squad
goals so it's actually no surprise that
a while back Universal tried to go the
way of the MCU and create a connected
universe with these iconic monsters
called the dark universe it kind of sort
of kicked off with 2014's brought in
Dracula untold starring Luke Evans and
then came to a screeching halt a few
years later with Tom Cruise into the
mummy after the big-budget film had a
poor box-office showing in the US and
was horribly received by critics and
fans Universal chairwoman Donna Langley
ultimately called the idea of a
connected dark universe a failed
experiment kind of like Frankenstein and
that meant all sorts of projects
featuring the stars in this photo from
2017 just pretty much went away
including Bride of Frankenstein with
Javier Bardem and possibly Angelina
Jolie and Invisible Man film starring
Johnny Depp and no doubt Russell Crowe
reprising his role of dr. Jekyll and mr.
Hyde from The Mummy
so the new plan or pivot if you will is
to focus more on filmmakers bringing
their own unique approach to these
characters in standalone films so think
less Marvel and more like DC's latest
move with the standalone hit Joker
this also means steering away from big
budgets which rarely works in horror
anyway and that's why with the budget of
just nine million for the Invisible Man
its strong opening weekend of twenty
nine million at the u.s. box office was
a huge win for a man you can see he
stopped dead he has to figure it out a
way to be invisible so what does the
success of the Invisible Man mean for
the future of this new filmmaker driven
dark universe
well more standalone stories from
big-time names for one a new original
project called dark army is reportedly
in the works written and directed by
Paul Feig and featuring a mix of classic
Universal Monsters and original
characters so like the Avengers of the
dark universe there's also the Dracula
theme rent filled with Rocket Man
director Dexter Fletcher attached and
according to Variety Oscar nominated
producer Amy Pascal is now the one
trying to bring the Bride of
Frankenstein back to the big screen can
we bring back her hairstyle to please
and completely unrelated to the
Invisible Man is the Invisible Woman
with Elizabeth Banks set to direct and
star in totally it's being described as
delma and Louie's meets American Psycho
which means it's gonna be awesome well
while the Invisible Woman won't be
connected to the Invisible Man
not to give too much away the latter
does leave the door open for an
invisible sequel so any potential
confusion would need to be sorted out
and at this point both Elizabeth moss
and writer director Leigh Whannell have
said that they haven't given a sequel
much thought yet in other words let's
just wait and see how much money this
movie makes
yo we have our first look at the new
Batmobile for next year's of Batman and
we're kind of freaking out so just like
we did after we saw the new bad 2 and
heard about the film's cast we're gonna
take a look at the new whip and tell you
what it tells us about the Batman on the
kitchen you guys Matt Reeves has done it
again do you think he's just uploading
pics on his phone like yeah I'm about to
burn the Internet up right now totally I
mean no complaints here because just
like the suit this time Reeves drop
photos of the new Batmobile the most
iconic symbol of Batman and it's
basically like a lamborghini miura drift
car which is arguably the greatest
compliment you can give a vehicle my
boss Jimmy told me to say that and it
totally does reactions on Twitter are of
course a little bit split with some
users totally loving it and others not
so much Erica on facebook said looks as
if the guys from Fast and Furious
delivered the car to Bruce Wayne I feel
like it looks like Bruce took the
Batmobile to West Coast Customs and
exhibit was like yo Dawg we heard you
like breaking so we put red brake lights
on your car ok so what does this new
version of the Batmobile tell us about
the Batman which opens in June of 2021
well looking back at previous Batman
films the babble wheel is one of the
main things that represents the overall
tone of a Batman movie even more so than
the bat suit or the utility belt take a
look at the Michael Keaton timbre and
era Batmobile from 1989 s Batman and
1992 s Batman Returns versus ride was
very sleek and dark and for the time a
bit eccentric which in a lot of ways
mirrors those movies
but then came the Val Kilmer and George
Clooney era with Batman Forever and
Batman and Robin where the Batmobile
went from being a little campy to
flat-out cheesy
not to mention oh so very 90s but like
Robin once said chicks dig the card
including this one this is why Superman
works alone when Christopher Nolan took
over the franchise at Christian Bale's
Bruce the Batmobile from Batman Begins
and the Dark Knight had a military feel
and was more about using technology to
optimize peak performance and pretty
much look like something dan Bilzerian
would drive and of course we have bat
flicks Batmobile from Batman V Superman
dawn of Justice and Suicide Squad this
thing was just a rough tumble killing
machine kind of like Ben Affleck Batman
but I gotta wonder does it bleed we just
put Ben's voice over mine so that brings
us to the latest version of the
Batmobile which feels pretty vintage and
close to the og Adam West's Batmobile
which was sick and kind of just looked
like the car that was decked out this
makes sense because we're gonna be
seeing a younger Batman in this movie
that's just starting out and doing
everything on his own and much like the
new bad suit this car is pretty stylish
and almost feels like they lifted Batman
off the cover of Esquire and I am here
for it so it's not surprising that and
remember this for trivia night the new
Batmobile was done by designer ash Thorp
a guy with some serious cult status
after working on films like Blade Runner
20 49 plus he's got his own new DeLorean
design so let Tom Holland know that the
Back to the Future reboot officially
needs to happen peg Tom what and while
we're talking bad vehicles set photos
that were snapped recently of the new
bat-cycle show a more modest approach to
this Batman's vehicles a far cry from
the two-wheeled ride that carried the
name Batpod in the Christian Bale films
as far as how this car compares to the
long line of cinematic Batmobiles before
it we pose that question in our Facebook
fan group and Addison said I really like
the more simplistic look I'm excited to
see a potentially grounded and somewhat
realistic portrayal I agree with you
Addison I mean let's get walking
Phoenix's Joker in there 2020 for
nothing happy International Women's Day
in honor of the day we're celebrating
just a fraction of all the incredible
work done by women in film behind the
camera as we bring you guys five of the
best female directed films of the 21st
century right now on the ketchup just so
you know our full list of the best
female directed movies of the 21st
century is at Rotten Tomatoes com so go
check that out and then while you're
there open up your Facebook tab and join
our fan groups so we can talk about the
list but here are some highlights from
it just to get the conversation going
starting with one that is pretty
wonderful because it's Wonder Woman
directed by patty Jenkins we don't need
the lasso of truth to know that this
film kicked ass at the box office it
made over 821 million worldwide and
kicked ass with both critics and fans
like audience member Margot Q who said
no words to describe how powerful and
remarkable this movie is Thank You DC
patty Jenkins and gal gadot I mean
Wonder Woman was a game changer for
female led superhero films this was
Patty's first time ever doing a
big-budget action movie in her 14-year
career and she knocked it out of the
park and lucky for us she's back as the
director and writer of Wonder Woman 1984
coming out this June I'll just have to
keep rewatching those Super Bowl Tide
commercials until then we wanted to do
that today tomorrow also landing on our
list is Greta Gerwig 2017 hit Lady Bird
and I should also mention that girl Ruiz
film Little Women that came out this
past year was also a huge success but
Lady Bird is well put Gerwig on the
filmmaking map with Oscar nominations
for Best Picture directing and
screenplay
and going forward she will be bringing
her magic to a live-action feature film
based on Barbie don't know if it'll be
wrapped in plastic but I do know it'll
be fantastic
are you another great film on this list
is director Ava Duvernay Selma from 2014
it was nominated for a Best Picture
Oscar and tells the story of Martin
Luther King jr. and the tragic events
leading up to one of the most
significant victories in the civil
rights movement for equal voting rights
but Duvernay is no stranger to directing
certified fresh' films she won top
honors at Sundance in directing for
2012's middle of nowhere and went on to
direct the Emmy winning and Oscar
nominated documentary 13 in 2016
another great one from artis lists of
the best female directed films of the
21st century is Kathryn Bigelow's The
Hurt Locker this war action thriller
from 2009 earned Bigelow a Best
directing Oscar and it became the first
ever female directed film to win an
Oscar for Best Picture insane that it
took that long after that Bigelow went
on to direct the oscar-nominated zero
dark thirty which starred Jessica
Chastain who was nominated for Best
Actress oh yeah um I found this place so
and finally before we ride on out here
we got to talk about the writer director
Chloe Zhou's hit from 2018 the writer
this film is based on a true story about
a rising rodeo star whose careers cut
short after a tragic riding accident
after the rider became a hit with both
fans and critics now is officially a
rising star in filmmaking enough so that
she was hired to direct the highly
anticipated Marvel movie Eternals coming
out later this year from Cowboys to
superheroes I can't say I'm not jealous
director of Eternals Chloe Zhou
[Applause]
all right friends thanks for tuning into
the weekly ketchup on YouTube make sure
you tap that subscribe button and
notification Bell so you don't miss out
on any future episodes of the ketchup as
always I'm NASA Prez and we'll see you
guys next week
[Music]
[Music]